in this video I want to talk about every
thrill poetic proto porphyria or EPP
sometimes called proto porphyria which
is the second of two chronic urethral
porphyrios and actually EPP is the most
common urethra poor Faria the other one
of course being the very rare congenital
erythropoietic porphyria or CEP in
addition the EPP being the most commonly
report Faria it's the third most common
porphyria the first of course being PCT
porphyria cutanea tarda
and the second being AIP acute
intermittent porphyria okay EP P
specifically is an autosomal dominant
deficiency of Pharaoh Kela tastes
sometimes call it heme synthase they'll
more commonly call it Pharaoh Aquila
taste we've got some key features here
that present themselves pretty early
somewhere in childhood infancy and the
way I remember that funny enough is an
episode of house m.d. which I hope
you're not hating on me for watching
there was a case where the diagnosis was
EPP and it was the patient was a little
girl like an elementary school-aged girl
okay and one of the big things was that
she was photosensitive
okay so that's the main feature in EPP
is photo sensitivity which we've seen in
the other porphyrios but here two
different kind of photo sensitivity here
we it leads to swelling itching burning
and redness on the Sun exposed area to
the skin but there's no blistering or
scarring that we saw on the other part
furious that's an important key
difference there the photo sensitivity
does not lead to blistering and scarring
but there is plural sensitivity right
swelling itching burning and redness in
addition to that there's also the
accumulation of protoporphyrin 9 which
is proximal to the block right and
that's naming the blood plasma red blood
cells skin liver and feces but not in
the urine cuz it's nonpolar it's just
excreted in the feces
but the blockage is right here due to
the lack of pharoah Keela taste right
and so protoporphyrin ein will
accumulate leading to that photo
sensitivity also it's possible that
liver and gall problems
gallbladder problems will be associated
with EPP looks like liver failure
gallstones cholestasis something like
that may be associated with EPP okay but
it's mainly just though the the
photosensitivity that's the issue along
with the accumulation of that protocol
for a 9 ok
you
you